Hi, I'm Beau Carnes with Free Code Camp. In
this course, I will teach you how to create
a very simplified Heroku clone. This course is
really all about how to provision infrastructure
programmatically. Heroku is a platform as a
service that allows developers to build, run
and operate applications entirely in the cloud.
Heroku makes it easy to do things such as deploy
virtual machines, to host applications. And to
deploy websites into the cloud. Some of the things
that Heroku offers can actually be done pretty
easily with other tools. In this course, I will
teach you how to develop a simple web app that
will allow users to provision virtual machines,
and deploy static web apps, all at the click
of a button, and hosted on Amazon Web Services.
So this is what the Heroku clone is going to look
like. Like I mentioned, it's very simplified,
it just has two options to deploy your own
static website, or set up a virtual machine
for development and testing. So let me just show
you what this looks like. So you go here, and
it's going to show a list of the sites, these are
ones that have already been created, we can also
create a new site where you can put in the name,
and then you can put in a URL where it will get
that HTML code right from that URL, or you can
type in your own HTML. And then when you click
Create, it will create that site will deploy
right to AWS. And then I'll tell you about
what some of these like the viewing console. I'll
tell you about that later in the actual course.
But and then clicking the links here will actually
open up the sites. Again, you'll see that more in
the actual course, let me just show you what it
looks like when you create the virtual machine.
So here, we can create a virtual machine.
And then you can choose the instance type.
And with the virtual machine, you're always gonna
have a public key. This is a way that it can be
authenticated. After you after the virtual machine
has deployed the AWS, we can SSH into that, but we
need to authenticate it with our private key. So
those are all the features you're going to be able
to deploy and destroy, delete these things right
from AWS. So right from this web interface, we'll
be able to create the virtual machine on the site.
And also we can delete the virtual machines and
the websites, all from our web interface. We don't
even have to log into AWS to do any of that stuff.
And then also, I'll show you how to make a
JavaScript version of one section of this.
At the very end of the course. Provisioning
infrastructure is related to platform
engineering. A platform engineering team
serves an organization by planning, designing
and managing its cloud platforms. And often this
can be done programmatically. The tools I teach
in this course can be used for much more than
just provisioning VMs and deploying websites,
they can be used for platform engineering to
make it simpler to manage cloud platforms.
This course focuses on the automation API from
plumie plumy provide a Free Code Camp grant that
made this course possible. pulumi is open source
infrastructure as code SDK allows you to create,
deploy and manage infrastructure on any cloud
using a variety of programming languages.
Their automation API makes it possible to
provision infrastructure programmatically using
the plumie engine. Basically, it makes it simple
to write a program that automatically creates VMs,
databases, V PCs, static websites, and more
on a variety of different cloud platforms.
I'm going to show you how to create our Heroku
clone a web app using flask and Python on the back
end. However, you don't already have to know
how to use flask and Python to follow along.
Also, everything I show you could also be
done with many other different frameworks and
programming languages. And many of the steps are
the same. No matter what web framework you use,
our app will provision resources on AWS. But
Paluma makes it simple to provision resources
on most of the major cloud providers. And it
wouldn't take that much updating to the code
to use a different provider. Thanks to Kamal
Ali who created the code that my code and
this course is based off of. So let's start
making the application. By the way at the end,
I'll also show you how to use the automation API
to provision infrastructure using JavaScript. So
you can see how it's different between JavaScript
and Python and also see how it's very similar.
So let's start setting everything up. I've
already created a directory on my computer called
Heroku pool, which is where we're going to be
creating the project. We first need to make sure
that we have the plumie CLI installed. The way to
install is different depending on your operating
system. If you have Mac OS, you can just do brew
install pulumi. And if you have Windows you can do
Chaco install Pulu me. Both those assume that
you either have homebrew or chocolaty installed,
check the link in the description
for other ways of installing pulumi.
Now, this project also uses AWS, so you'll
have to make sure you have an AWS account,
and you have the CLI set up and authenticated,
you can sign up for a free AWS account at the link
in I have a link in the description that
will show you how to sign up for a free
AWS account. And then there's another link that
shows you how to install the AWS CLI, it's going
to be different depending on your operating
system. Once you have the AWS CLI installed, you
can configure it by just doing AWS Configure. And
then the first thing you're going to have to do is
put in your AWS access key. Again, I'm going to
put a link in the description to how you do that,
because Amazon has some very specific instructions
on how to get an AWS access key. But once you have
the access key, you can enter it, you can enter
the secret access key. And then you can choose
your default Region Name, I'm just going to
keep it as the default here, which is AWS,
the US reason to default output format, you
may just want to keep all those the same.
And after that's configured, it's time to
set up the plumie project. A plumie project
is just a directory with some files in it, it's
possible for you to create a new one by hand,
or you can use the plumie new command. So
that's what we're going to do to pulumi.
New, this is using the plumie CLI. Okay, it
says please choose a template or mine does.
If this is the first time you've used pulumi,
you'll be directed to enter an access code or
login. So it's gonna give you a URL to go to.
And you may have to make a plumie account. But
once you enter the access code, you'll see this
where it says please choose a template. So we're
going to choose AWS Python, we're going to be
creating a Python app that hosts resources on AWS.
And then we can choose things like the
project name, we do Heroku cool. Okay, looks
like it doesn't exist, because I've already it's
associated with my plumy account. And I've already
created a project with that name for a test. So
I'm going to create a another route, I'm going
to just call it something else, even though we
know that it's supposed to be called Hero. Cool.
So how about a row cool, too. Oh, okay. And
then you can just pick the defaults for this
stack, we're gonna keep the default, it's
going to initialize into a new stack called
Dev, which is an instance of our project,
every plumie program is deployed to a stack,
a stack is an isolated, independently configurable
instance of a plumie. Program. Stacks are commonly
used to denote different phases of development. In
this case, we're using Dev, so I'm just going to
use that. And then we can choose the AWS
region to to deploy to now keep in mind,
this is actually different than the default we
set before. And this is the one that's actually
going to be used US East one. And now you can
see it's creating the virtual environment.
Okay, install the bunch of libraries we're going
to need into our virtual environment. But we're
going to need a few more. So I'm going to do so
first I'll just list here, you can see we created
the plumie dot Yamo file that's used to configure
everything, the main.py file, which is where our
main Python code is going to go. The requirements
dot txt, which tells us our dependencies,
and then the V and V directory, this is our
virtual environment. And we are going to run
a program in the virtual environment. So normally,
when you're installing Python dependencies,
you use the program, Pip, but I'm going to make
sure to run the program PIP from our virtual
environment. So I'm gonna do V and V dot slash
bin slash Pip. And then I'm going to install flask
and requests. So these are to the dependencies.
So we were making a flask app, and the requests
library will allow us to make HTTP requests. So
after we get everything installed in our terminal,
I'm going to open up this folder in Visual Studio
code. Okay, so here's everything in Visual Studio
code, it has all the files I mentioned, such as
our configuration file, plumie, that Yamo, the
requirements, and then the main.py. This is where
our main Python code is going to go. And you can
see it installed some, putting some default code
here are going to end up changing most of this.
So we're gonna start off by actually changing
the name of this file to app.pi, it's common for
flask to be to be looking for a file called
app.py, for the flask app. So like I said,
we're gonna get rid of this code, we're gonna
eventually use some code similar to this. But
for now, I'm going to paste in some code here.
And I'll even zoom in just a little bit more. So
this is how to create the most basic flask app you
can create. And so we're importing flask, the app
is going to be flask with the name. And so this
is how you create a route in flask you do that
the app app, that's the app here. And then the
route is just going to be the default route slash.
And this is going to, it's going to basically just
when you go to this route with just a slash at
the end, it's going to run this function, it's
going to return hello world. And so let's just
test this out right now, I'm going to save
this, and then I'm going to, and then create
a new terminal window. And then I'm going
to just do vnv slash bin slash flask run.
Okay, it's giving me a URL to go to. So I will
just Ctrl click here. Okay, and here it is,
I'm going to zoom in here. So it just says,
Hello, world. Okay, so we've created a flask app.
And we've verified that flask is working
correctly. Okay, back in VS code, I'm going
to make my terminal get a little smaller here. So
I'll just stop the app for now until we've made
some more adjustments to our code. And I'm going
to actually paste in some all new code here. Now,
check, I'm going to be pasting in a lot of code
in this tutorial, you probably don't want to wait
around as they type in every single thing in here.
So I'm going to be pasting in some code and then
I'm going to be explaining what the different
parts do. So if you check in the description,
you can get a link to all the code that we are
using in this tutorial. So you can see first
we're importing OS, this is gonna allow us to
get an environment variable later. And then where
we are important we're getting, we're getting
flask because this we're making a flask app,
just like before. Now here is where we are
importing the plumie automation framework.
This is what I discussed earlier. So we're
importing blueys automation framework as a
variable called Auto. Then in the ensure plugins
function, we get access to the local workspace,
a N A, and this is something specific to
pulumi. A workspace is the execution context
containing a single plumie Project Workspaces
are used to manage the execution environment.
They provide various utilities
such as plugin installation,
environment, configuration, and creation, deletion
and listing of stacks. Now here we have the WS dot
installed plugins. Because we are deploying AWS
resources in this tutorial, we must install the
AWS provider plugin within the workspace so
that the plumie program will have available
during execution. And then we have the
create app function. This is what flask
will run when we start the flask app, we must
first ensure plugins we run this function here,
and then create the flask app. Now this is very
similar to what we saw in our example flask app
that we just tested before I put in this code app
equals flask. Now this app dot config dot from
mapping, this is also something specific to flask
not plumy. This function is used by flask to set
some default configurations that the app will
use. This will not be a production Ready app.
But if you ever deploy a flask app, make sure
to change the secret key, I just have a secret,
you can basically have this anything you
want. The other variables are used by pulumi.
So we have the project name of Heroku. Cool, too,
I updated this. At first, it was Heroku. Cool,
because that's what it was originally going to be
called. But remember, we call it Heroku. Two. So
this has been updated to Heroku. Two, you may want
to use Heroku, depending on what you call it, if
you're following along. And then we get the
environment variable, the plumie organization,
we get this, this environment variable. And
that's why we import an OS above. Now the
rest of this file is common to flask apps, we set
the default route here. And just what this slash
This is just like the example we already showed,
but now we are also setting the HTTP method. This
is for GET requests. Now, you probably already
know about HTTP methods and request. But a get
request is one of the most common requests when
you're getting information to your web browser.
So what we are getting the index html file, it's
going to return this template that index that HTML
template. This is an HTML file that we still
have to create. And basically, it's going to
render this file to the browser when someone
goes to this route. And then we have this here,
the file is going to import the sites and virtual
machines files, which we still have to create.
And it's registered them as a blueprint
register blueprint. A Blueprint in flask
is a way to organize a group of related views
and other code. Rather than registering views and
other code directly with an application. They're
registered with a blueprint, then the blueprint
is registered with the application when it is
available in the factory function. Basically,
we're using blueprints. So we can define
additional routes for webapp. In other files,
it's all just about being able to create
some routes and these other files.
So speaking of other files, let's create some.
So I'm going to create a directory called
templates. So let's click the new directory.
And this is going to be called templates.
And then I'm going to create a file called index
dot HTML. And then I'll paste in some code here.
Here's the index html. Again, you can get all
this code at the link in the description. I won't
go into too much detail about this code. It's
basic HTML, but anything inside curly braces,
like this block content, this is in curly
braces here. This isn't curly braces. Basically,
anything inside the curly braces is an expression
that will be output to the final document.
Flask uses the Jinja template library to render
templates. So we can use the curly braces,
the Jinja templates, to dynamically render things,
like for instance, soon, we're going to use it to
dynamically render a list of the sites and
virtual machines that the user has created.
And then we can also access variables that we
create in the Python code, we can then put the
variables in these curly braces to make them
appear on in our in our website and the front
end of our website. And you can see we can get
specific URLs. So it's getting the URL for this
site that lists sites. Now, this is something
we're going to create in our Python file, we're
going to create a list sites function. And this
is going to be a specific route that we set up
in our Python file. And this URL for function will
be able to get that that URL basically. So next,
let's create a new file, you can already see that
this extends base dot HTML. So there should be a
when it displays is going to display is the
base dot HTML is going to come before the
rest of this content. So I'll save this and I'm
going to create this new file. And it's going to
be called base dot HTML. Okay, I'm going to paste
in this. Yeah, so this is going to have a header.
And it's going to have another container that's
going to have different flash messages. So
our app is going to be able to flash up alerts
and messages to to the user. And that's going
to be all of this is going to be at the top of
every page in our website. So I'll just say that.
And now we're going to pretty quickly
create the rest of our HTML templates.
And then we'll Create the Python files that do the
real heavy lifting in our app, and will go much
slower through the Python files, the Python files
are going to be what actually using plumie to
create the different resources on AWS. So
we're going to inside this Templates folder,
I'm going to create two more directories,
I'm going to create the site's directory.
And I'm going to create the virtual machines.
Directory, oh, these weren't supposed to be within
each other. Silly. Move that, okay, so they're
both in the same root level. And each of
these are going to have the same three files,
they're going to have an index that HTML file,
a create that HTML file and an update that
HTML file and the same for virtual machines.
In will paste in stuff here. And I want
to kind of point out some things here.
So it's going to start with the
base html, it's going to have this
navigation here. But the real thing we want to
look at is, it's going to, the real thing we
want to look at is going to it's going to take
information from our Python code that we still
have to read, to have to write specifically,
there's going to be a list called sites.
If there's no sites, it's just going
to say no websites are currently
deployed, create one to get started. And then the
URL for sites that create site, which will go to
this create that HTML, and it's going to allow
people to create a site. But then if if there
are sites, it's going to loop this for site and
sites. And it's going to add this free site. So
you can see it's getting the URL for the site, and
then the the name for the site. And it's getting a
URL to delete the site, and to update the slides.
And you can see the ID is the site name, the site
name, so it's getting all this information from
the site's list that we are going to create in
Python in this site is actually going to this list
of sites is going to come right from plumie, when
you use plumie to get this list of sites that have
been created on AWS, to show on this index page.
And then then there's the console URL, you'll see
what all this is in a minute. So I'm not going to
talk too much about these other ones. It's pretty
self explanatory. It's just basic HTML, all the
functionality comes on the Python. And so that's
what we're going to really focus on talking about.
Now, the Create and Update are very similar.
It's it's doing basically similar things except
update will have some
information already filled in.
And then I'm just going to add this code
for the virtual machines files, which is
just like for the site's except it's going to be
showing information about the virtual machines.
So here, it's going to like if if there are
if there's no VMs, no virtual machines are
currently deployed. But if there are VMs. So it's
going to be able to have a link to delete the VM,
update the VM. And here, it's giving a
command to SSH into the virtual machine.
And we're going to actually try this out later
after we create a virtual machine with this app.
We're going to SSH into it. And it's always going
to start with this same line. And then it's going
to have the DNS name it's getting see what the
curly braces so it's getting that directly from
the from the Python side, where we've stored
the DNS name for each virtual machine. Okay,
now we'll do the Create. There's nothing
too fancy in the Cray it's just a web form
to insert certain information for our virtual
machine. And then we have the update one.
And this is to update information
in the virtual machine.
Now I'm just going to make sure all these files
are saved and exiting the close some of these,
I'm not really going to need
to go back into these views.
These templates, I mean, now it's time to
create the functionality of our Heroku clone
using Python. So the app.py file imports from
these files that we still have to create.
So in the same directory as app.py
Let's create sites.py. So, new file
sites.py. So now that we got the site's dot
py, I'm going to paste in some code here.
And these are all just the basic imports that
we need for flask and plumy, including importing
the automation framework right here. And then we
import s3 from plumie, AB AWS, to interact with
AWS and create an s3 bucket. And then there's
BP equals a blueprint, we see the URL prefix is
slash sites. So we are going to be defining what
happens when people go to the URL slash sites. Now
I'm going to paste in some more code and then
describe what it does here. So here's a new
function Create plumie program. And it's going to
take a parameter, it which is going to be a string
content. So on the front end of this web app that
we're creating this Heroku pool, people can create
a website, they can deploy a website by
inputting the HTML that makes up the website,
the HTML that the that the users put into the web
form, becomes this content, and gets passed on to
this create plumie program function. Later, we're
going to be creating some routes and functions
that call this create plumie program function and
pass in the HTML text, that's going to become the
content of the website that users are trying
to create. So this function defines our plumy,
s3 static website in terms of the content
that the color passes in, it will allow us to
dynamically deploy websites based on user defined
values from the post body. So if we go in here,
we can see that first we're creating a
bucket and exposing a website index document.
And then we're going to write the index dot
HTML into the site bucket. So we have s. So
again, the s3, this is this is part of pulumi
is part of plumy to create an s3 bucket, and
we're creating the bucket object. And the bucket,
the ID is the site bucket that ID, which is going
to be come from the bucket that we created up
here, the content is the index content, which
is what the user passed in as the HTML of the
file, then we have the key in the content type.
And then we are going to set the access policy
for the bucket. So all objects are readable. Now,
the way this gets set is specific to AWS.
So that's where all of this is coming from,
like this date is actually specific to
AWS that we have to pass in for this.
And you'll be able, so depending on what
you're going to do, you just have to look up
what information you need for AWS to
create a bucket. And then finally,
we are going to export the website URL. So
the purpose of this Paluma dot export command
that that you see here is to export a named
stack output, exported values are attached to
the program's stack resource. Later, we will
see how we can access this data that's being
exported. It's kind of like an environment
variable. So this is the key, it's like a
key value pair. The key is the website URL. The
value is site bucket, that website endpoint, this
is going to be the URL that we get directly from
AWS, after deploying this site to the s3 bucket.
And then the website content. This is just the the
content of the the HTML of the website that we get
here. So far, nothing is calling this function. So
at this point, let's create URL endpoints that can
be used to call that function we just created
to create websites. So first, we will create a
may persist, but this is a new route. So at slash
new so first is going to be slash sites. And then
after the end of slash site is slash new, and
this will respond to both GET and POST requests.
So you First, we're going to
check if it's a post request.
And let's just go down to see what happens
if it's a get request. If it's a get request,
it's going to return render the template sites
slash create the create that HTML. But if it's
a post request, that means the user has already
went has already done the get request, they fill
in the form. And now they're sending data to the
same URL. And this is what we're going to do with
that. Now you see this request that form that get?
Well we got requests, that's as part of flask,
and this is part of, oh, are the go. This is how
we access the information that's sent with the
form. And the information is different key value
pairs. So the user will have put in the site ID
into the form. And now we're getting that and
we're setting it to be the stack name. And then
the user will have put in a file URL, possibly,
maybe not. So the way it works, the user can
put in the file URL, which is the URL they want to
upload to the s3 bucket, or they can type in the
HTML. And that's going to be the site content.
So first, we're going to get the fire URL,
if there is a file URL, then we'll set the site
content to now request that get this is going
to be doing a an HTTP request to whatever URL
that the person passed in and getting the text.
Or we're just going to get whatever
the user typed into the site content.
And then we're going to find a function
plumie program where we're going to
call this function here the Create plumie program
function. And we pass in the site content,
the string of the site content. So that's how we
actually create the website. But this function
hasn't been called yet. Because we're going to
do that within this try catch block. So a try
catch this is just if you're not familiar, if
you don't know a lot about Python, it's just an
error handling thing. So we try the code in
here. And if there's an error, then it's going to
do what's down here. So the first thing that's
gonna happen says Create new stack generate,
generating our plumie program on the fly from the
post body. So you can see Auto is the automation
framework out that create stack. As a reminder,
every plumie program is deployed to a stack,
a stack is an isolated independently configurable
instance of a plumie program. In this code, the
stack name is based on the ID, that the user typed
into the form. So my stack name right here was
the ID. And then we got the project name, and
then the plumie program, and pulling the program
is this, which uses plumie to create the website
on AWS. Now, it's not going to run the program,
until we get down here, stack that up. If you
had the, if you're on the plumie CLI, you would
do clue me up. But first, we're going to make sure
we have the correct way we can set the AWS region.
Now there would already be one as default. But you
could you could set a different AWS region here.
And then we deploy. So stack that up. And then
it's going to says output print. So this is going
to print all the output so in the terminal, and
then we have a flash. So this is going to flash
up on the website successfully created site, or it
may flash up an error. So this data up, let's just
I'm going to talk a little bit more about that.
Because once the stack is created, we can execute
commands against the stack, including update,
preview, refresh, destroy, import, and export.
So stack that up is to up date the stack. And then
you can pass in the a callback, which I already
discussed, which is going to print to the standard
output. Okay, I'm gonna add a new section of code,
which we will discuss. And this is going to
be a new route. This is just to the the route
route the slash, but it's not just slash because
it's still going to take into account the sites.
So if you just go to slash site slash, it's going
to list all the sites this is a get request.
And it's going to so this variable right here
site, it's the list. This is what's going to be
passed into our template our front end, once
it's full of sites, it will be passed in,
and then it can display the list of sites,
we're gonna get the org name, the project name.
And then it's going to try this. And then
if it's an error, we'll just go down to
this except here. But the first thing is going
to do is get the automation framework that local
workspace, a workspace is the execution context
containing a single plumie project, a program
and multiple stacks. So here we're getting access
to the workspace. And then we are passing in the
project name of the workspace, then we have lists,
stacks. So this just gives us access to the stack
name. So we also have all stacks is just gonna be
the names of all the stacks. So now we have to get
access to the specific stacks. So that's why we do
auto dot select stack, and we pass in the stack,
we're trying to get stack dot name, and the
project name. And then whenever you do select
stack, you can pass in a program, but we don't
want the program to do anything. So that's why
just lambda none. So select select stack
is very similar. If we scroll up here to
create stack, so create stack and select stack
have similar parameters. So in this case,
the program was to run this plumie program. But
when we're selecting the stack, we're not going
to run any program or anything. That's why we
just have a basically a blank function here.
And out equals select outputs. So remember, when
we initially created it up here, we export things.
So the outputs are going to actually just be this
information. So we're getting the website URL,
and the website content for each
item, easily each website. And
once we get the information, if the website URL
isn't out, then we'll append this information
to the site where this is what's being passed to
their front end, the name stack that name the URL.
So it's going to be the the website URL,
and then the console URL. So cancel URL.
This just means where we can access information
about this on the plumie website. That's one great
thing about plumie is that you can get information
about your application through the command line,
and through different ways through your program.
Or you could also go to the plumie website,
every time you're you're creating a stack, every
time we're creating a site or virtual machine,
we can go to the plumie website to get
information about that, about that whatever
resource we created. So I'll show you that later
when we try out this program that we're making.
And then if there's an exception, we will flash
this to the person. And then we we're going to
return this, we're going to render the template.
And it's the index html template. And we're going
to pass in sites equal sites. So now we want
to enter the template and path in the sites.
That means if you remember, we'll just look at
that really quick. But if we go to the index, it's
looking for each site in that list to to display.
Okay, I'm going to save that. And we're going to
add a little bit more to this file. So I'm going
to paste this in. And we're going to talk about
this. So this is the update route. First is going
to be the ID of the site slash update. And this
can be a get request or a post request. So first,
it's going to receive the ID into this function
here. And we're going to store as the stack name.
So if it's a post request, first, let's
see what happens if it's a get request.
So if it's a get request, it's going to render
this template, update that HTML because the person
wants to update it. And then once it actually is
updated, it's a post request. And it's going to
do this now this is going to look very similar to
our previous function. When when someone creates a
new site, it's very similar to when
they're updating the site. So we get the,
this is all the same the fire value Well, first we
get the site content. We have the plumie program,
we have the Select stack. Now
this is all pretty much the same.
We do stack that up. We do stack that up to update
it. One good thing about updating with plumie
It's going to see what's changed and only update
those things and not not going to just update
everything, it's going to only update whatever
has changed. So even though we're putting all this
thing, all this stuff here, it's only going
to figure out what changed and update that.
And then we're going to flash successfully
updated, we have air. And then it's going to
redirect to sites that list sites, which was
just our slash, so not the update the index.
But then this is what happens if it's a
get request, first, we're going to get the
stack and then the stack that outputs so we can
get the website content. And then the website
content will be used when we render the template,
because that's where we want the content of the
website to show in the in the update section. So
users can see what they're updating. And there's
only one more section to this file, which is the
Delete route. So I'm going to paste in this here.
Now this is very straightforward. So if the the
the route is the ID slash, delete, it's a post.
And there's not even any GET request here that
so there's no page for delete, and you just
click the Delete button, and then it's going to
delete. So we get the, so we have a stack name,
we're going to first wait to select the stack,
then stack dot destroy. So previously, we did
stacked stacked up to update it. But here we're
going to destroy and then remove the stack.
And this is a cool thing about plumy. Just doing
stack that destroy, it's automatically going to
delete the resource on AWS. So whether it's
an s3 bucket, whether it's a virtual machine,
or whatever resource that we create on AWS,
just doing stack that destroy will delete it.
So it's not going to charge you any money
anymore, because it's just completely
deleted off of AWS. And then it's
going to flash the message. And then
there's a few possible exceptions that could
happen. And then it's just going to read redirect
to the list of sites. Okay, this file is done.
And there's really just one more file to create,
which is kind of similar to this file, it's
the same one, but for virtual machines.
So I am going to go up here to new
file, and this is going to be called
virtual machines.pi. Now, this time, I'm
just going to paste in the whole thing,
and they're going to go through it, it's a little
bit longer. But there's so much similarities,
we're not going to have to go through everything.
Because the automation framework makes working
with different types of resources, very
similar. It's not exactly the same, because
AWS is going to require different information
when you create different types of resources. But
the whole top section is basically the
same. Now here we have instance types,
because when you're creating a virtual machine
on AWS, you have to choose what type of instance
you're going to use for your virtual machine.
And, in reality, there's way more options on AWS
than these three. But for this example, we're
going to give the user three different options.
But you could easily add more to this list here.
And so here we're going to create the program.
And right now the only thing that the user will be
able to choose is the instance type. Or you could
make it so a user could create it could do could
choose other options. So here, this is the plumie
library, but all this information is specific to
AWS. So when you're creating a virtual machine,
you're going to first have to get access to the
AMI. And then we have specific information here.
that's specific to AWS. And we
also need the security group.
And so we specify this and it's going this is how
we're going to enable SSH access access because we
want to be able to SSH into our virtual
machine, which we will actually do,
I'll show you how to do that once we get this all
set up. Now this is going to be something that's
different with the virtual machine than the the
website hosted on s3, we are going to have a key.
We're going to have a private a public private
key pair. This is going to basically provide
authentication when we want to access
the virtual machine to make it so only
the person who created the virtual machine can
access it and not just anybody can get into it.
When we're creating the virtual machine on AWS,
we must give a public key then in order to access
the VM Em, you have to have the private key. So
what this is doing here is getting the public key
information from our local file system. So
we're getting the path. And it's just accessing
this path, the home path, to access the public
key on the file system. Now this is a file, and
we're going to actually have to make sure we have
created this file. So when this goes to access it,
it's already there. Now this, this directory, this
directory structure is generally the same on both
Mac and Windows and Linux. So whatever operating
system you have, this path is, this should work
no matter what operating system you have. And the
way that we're going to create the key value pair,
it puts it into the same directory, basically,
no matter what operating system you have.
So this is something that when you're creating
the virtual machine through the web interface,
you're going to have to put in the string of
characters, which is your public key. And then
later, when you SSH into the virtual machine,
you have to make sure you have the private key
on your computer. So it can validate that you
are the person who owns this virtual machine.
And I'll be showing you how to do all of that
and just a little bit, but it's going to strip
all the whitespace from the public key is going to
print the public key. Remember, public keys can be
a public knowledge, anybody can know your public
key, but you don't want anybody to know your
private key. And we're going to create a key pair.
And this is specific to AWS, how this is created.
And then we are going to have to get the server.
And you can see we're passing in the security
group, the key pair, the instance type, and the
AMI, this is all stuff that we created earlier.
And then it's going to do a bunch of exports, the
instance type public key public IP and public DNS.
And this is the information that we're going to
be able to use to access it through SSH. Okay,
now, this was just the function, we just have
to make the routes to use the function. So just
like before we have the new route, we are going
to get the form data, the form that is going to
have the ID, which is just something that a user
makes up and it's going to become the stack name,
someone, the user is going to enter the key, the
public key, which is now going to be the key data.
And then they're going to choose instance type.
And remember, the instance type is going to be
one of these three options that is going to be
basis can be a drop down menu on the front end.
And that's going to be stored as instance type.
And then with the plumie program, it passes in the
key data and the instance type. And then the rest
of this is very similar where we create the stack.
And then we configure it, and then stack that up.
And then on success on not success,
then it's going to list the VMs again.
And then this current app, that logger, this
is just going to make sure information is we'll
just log this information of the instance types.
Now, if someone did a get request, it's going to
go to the Creator HTML that everything else was
the post request. And when does the Creator HTML,
it's going to pass in some data, the instance
types, because this is going to become a drop
down menu on in, in the index that create that
HTML file. And the current instance type is none.
And then we have the this is just where it lists
all the VMs because it's just slash it's a get
request. And it's going to be very similar to what
we've already looked at. Let's see what's new. The
only real new thing in this compared to what we've
already looked at in the sites is what's being
outputted Well, I mean, what's gonna be in the
list, but you get the DNS DNS name, but everything
else is basically the same. And then the update
will update is going to be very similar to when
you're creating something new. I guess the only
really the only difference when you're updating it
is that when this renders update HTML, it's going
to have a current instance type. Whereas when you
create a new one, there was no current instance
type. There's also we already have the public key,
the stack name and the instance types. And
then we have delete So now this is going to be
almost exactly the same as the site's one because
we just have to get access to the stack and
destroy it. And it's going to completely destroy
the virtual machine from Amazon dot AWS. Now, this
can be super helpful, because if you've done any
work on AWS, especially if you're just learning,
you may find out the hard way that if you turn
on things on AWS and forget to turn them off,
it can start charging you a lot of money. But
when you just do stack that destroy, well,
that will just delete everything, and you will no
longer be charged the money anymore. So even with
this example, it's going to cost us a little
bit of money, but just a few cents as long as
you destroy it right away. Okay, I'm going to save
this. And now I'm going to show you how to set up
your key value pair, there is a program called SSH
key Gen, and this is on both Mac and Windows. So
you may already have it on your computer. If not,
you can just look up SSH key Gen, a search for it
and find out how to get it installed. But we're
just going to run this SSH key Gen program to
create a new key private public key pair. So
I'm going to type in done to my terminal here,
SSH key, Jen and dash m and I'm going to make up
the type PIM and this is the type that you need
to use for AWS and I'm just gonna press enter and
then enter file missus save the key. Now I'm just
going to go do the default and you and then you
probably going to want to use a passphrase here
Okay, now I've created it. Now we're
going to go to that directory just
to make sure we have it in there. So
I'm going to change to the directory.
Now this is the file we just created. But you're
going to have to make sure it has a a.pm pe M
extension, I already have this because I already
created one with a dot p m extension. So you're
gonna want to rename this. Now, it's different
depending on what kind of operating system you
have. But one way to rename on Mac and is just MV,
you just put in the the name here. And then in v
means move. So I'm moving it from one name to the
other name. So I'm going to just put RSA dot PEM.
So on Windows and you could basically do the same
thing. But instead of doing MV for move, you're
going to type and rename, so renaming a put the
first file, and then what do you what you want to
be. So this is our public key. So if you remember,
our program will try to get that public key file.
But you can also enter it as your key
data. So you can either open up that file,
and copy the key and then paste it into
our web interface. Or if you don't,
if you just don't put anything, it
will try to get that information
on its own. Okay, now let's see, let me
just get back into their other directory.
And then we're going to run our flask app,
I'm going to start a little differently, so I
can put in some environment variables first.
So see I'm putting in the port, the environment,
the plumie organization, and then I'm going to run
Okay, it's time to test this out. Okay,
this is looking good so far, except
we still need to create our CSS files. So let's
go back and make sure we get our CSS in there.
So it looks a little nicer than this. But we
do know that it is seems to be working so far.
So actually just pasted in these
files here. Static and this is just
Bootstrap. We're just using basic bootstrap for
our CSS. We're just trying to make it simple here.
So let's go back over and refresh. Okay, this is
looking good. I'm gonna zoom out a little bit.
Okay, so Heroku cool. And we can either create a
static website or a virtual machine. So let's test
to see if everything works. I'm going to click get
started. Okay, no websites are currently deployed
create one to get started. So here is where we
can create a name. And I'm going to just call it
Hello, world. And the name, there can't be any
spaces the way that we created this. So the
file URL, well, I'm not going to have a file URL,
I'm going to create some content. So I'm going to
do hello. And I'm going to make put in some HTML
here. So we can test to see if that works world.
And then I'm going to click Create.
And look at this successfully created site,
hello world. Now this, it could actually take a
while to create the site, especially if it's the
first one. So you just got to kind of wait a while
to see to finally kind of pop up like this.
And so let's test a few things. First of all,
I'm going to just click this. And it's going to
open the URL. And now let me zoom in so you can
see it hello world. And we see it's has bowled.
And you can see this URL, it's right on s3,
s3, this website is us. This is this one
Amazon in the us.com. So we have this website
on here. And if I click View, in console, well,
before I do that, let's go back to our Visual
Studio code. And you can see its output it website
content, website URL, resources it created for
resources. So we can see right in here
that actually created the resources.
And I'm going to try viewing and console
here. This is opening right on Hulu, me.
And then if you're signed in, then you can get
to here look at so it's Beau Carnes slash Hero,
Hero cool to slash hello world is zoom in a little
bit here. And then we can see the website content,
we can see the website URL. And then we can see
more information like configuration, secrets
management, we got some tags here. And we can see
all this information about our site here. And then
with resources, we can see additional information
about the the bucket is what bucket is used index
the policy. And then it's even going to give us
information about how to destroy things and change
things. But we don't need to do any of that.
Because we can do all that from our web interface.
We're going to actually try editing and deleting
this. But before I want to show it to you on
Amazon AWS. Now, the great thing about this
is you never really wouldn't need to check on
Amazon AWS bound, just see you show you what it
looks like on there. Okay, now I'm on my Amazon
AWS account, I'm on the s3 section. And you can
see the buckets. And you can see right here, here
is the bucket we just created. It's showing the
index file here. And it's showing here's the URL,
the URL that we were given that go that you can
use to access this file. If I go and I'm going to
just go back over here to show this here. Now I'm
going to go back to our web app, our Heroku. Cool.
And I'm going to first let's try a few things. I'm
going to edit it and then I'm going to delete it.
So first, I'm going to check to see if edit works.
And we're going to put this all in an h1 Tag
now just click update and it successfully updated.
Now I'm going to click here and let me refresh.
Oh no, I don't have to refresh. This is
with the h1 tag. So that's why it's all
way bigger than before. And with h1, bold
really doesn't do anything. So that's why
there's nothing no difference between hello and
world. So now I'm going to delete this resource
site HelloWorld successfully deleted. And then if
we go if we go back into the terminal here, we can
see that oh, it's going it's showing what it's
doing. It's it's going through and deleting all
these things. It's filling the bucket policy, the
bucket object, the the s3 bucket Add the stack,
it's deleting all of this stuff, anything that was
associated with it, it just deletes. And if I go
and refresh here on my am s3 page, oh, this bucket
is no longer found, it's now no longer in the
bucket list, it's completely deleted off Amazon
AWS. Now I'm going to try creating another one.
This time, I'm going to use a file URL. This
is just a game that I found on GitHub. So I
am going to see it's a, I just clicked on
the raw file. And we're just going to put
in this URL to see if it works, I'm going to
call a snake. And then I'm going to create
successfully created so they click here. And
now I am playing Snake, I just put in that URL.
And I can play this game cool. So
I'm just gonna close this for now.
And let's see what happens if I click Edit.
Well, now, we don't just have the URL here,
we have all the code that it got from the URL.
And now we can make any changes we want.
Like what if we want to change the canvas,
let's change how big this is, instead of 400 by
400, I'm going to put 1000 by 1000 and update that
Oh, Kevin, click here. And now wow, this is a
really big, this game is gonna be really easy
to not hit myself now. I think maybe the apples
still are all gonna be in this one little corner.
But I can go really far away. So I was
able to update the code right from there
Okay, and just so you can see what it
looks like if you have multiple ones,
we can call this test and test
and I'm just gonna hit Create
so now we have two here. And you can see it
creates an Amazon creates a bucket for each. For
each one that we create, there's a new bucket for
each website. And then if I click view on console,
you can see we can go back here
and we can see snake and test.
And then here we can even see for the
snake while we can see all the code
Okay, let's go back to here. And now we're
going to create a virtual machine. Create
a virtual machine. And this is going to be called
potato. And then you can choose your instance type
RS two c three that large. And then I can get
the text on my public key and paste it here.
But let's see what happens if I don't
even do that I just click Create
if I go back into my terminal, we can
see it actually found my public key
automatically. And it's now creating it. Now
I could have opened up that public key file
in a text editor and copy this and then paste it
into that text box. But this way is even easier.
And now it says it's done creating let's go
back over here. And it successfully created
the VM potato. Now let's find the in AWS is not
going to be under s3 should be under EC two.
Okay, so if I go over here, we can see that this
one is running. It's initializing right now.
And then here we can see more
information about our virtual machine.
But I'm gonna get this here And I'm going
to try connecting it to it through SSH.
So I'm gonna copy that. Now I'm back
in my terminal that's not in VS code.
And we're gonna paste in this URL here. And
you can see it's accessing our dot p m file.
I show do you want to continue? Yes.
And then the passphrase that we created that
I created when I was creating that file.
And I'm in, I'm now inside the virtual machine,
I can change directories. And you can see that
see, I can see all these directories,
right in this virtual machines,
I can now actually use this to create a web
server, or do anything I want with this Linux box.
And you can do it right through your terminal.
Now, the cost of these virtual machines adds up
much quicker than the cost of the sites.
So I'm gonna go ahead and delete this.
And all these actions can take some time.
But if you want one, you can always look
in the console to see what's happening. See,
it's still it's deleting this right now, that
can take some time because it's, it's deleting
everything associated with the virtual machine,
from AWS and from our records on plumie.
Okay, it just deleted everything. So let's try a
few things. First, look, it says the connection
was closed, closed by a remote host, I didn't even
have to do anything. It says successfully deleted.
And then if I go to my instances, it's
now saying instance state, terminated.
Okay, so now I'm not going to pay
any more money for this instance.
So we just created a very simplified version of
Heroku. And you can use the same principles and
concepts to create applications that provision all
sorts of other resources. And like I mentioned,
you can do it with a bunch of other programming
languages, and cloud service providers to show
you how it would work with different programming
languages. I'm now going to show you how to write
a simple JavaScript program that will provision
a web app on AWS, this won't have any front end,
but you'll be able to see how the code
is very similar to the Python code.
This is the type of thing that could be helpful if
you're involved with platform engineering. Okay,
I'm in VS code. And this time, I'm going to be
using Node js and JavaScript instead of Python.
Like I just said, there's not going to be any
front end to this program, we're going to deploy
an inline plumie program that will create
a static website using the automation API.
So it's gonna be a little different,
but you'll definitely see a lot of
similarities to what we just did with Python. So
first, let's start our project just with an npm
init. And this is just going to, we're just
going to use all these default settings here.
And this is just going to create a package dot
json file, so we can install some dependencies.
So first, we're going to be connecting to
AWS with plumie. So let's do NPM install
at pulumi slash AWS. So this will help us to
connect to AWS with our JavaScript program. Now,
we're going to install one more NPM and net
install or npm install at pulumi slash pulumi. So
this is just gonna be the basic pulumi program.
Okay, we got that done. And I can create my file.
And this is gonna be index.js. Okay,
just like with the Python section,
I'm gonna paste in some code, and then explain
what it all does. And there'll be a link to the
code in the description. So let me go back
up to the top. And we're first going to
require the plumie libraries that we just
installed the Bluemix is Bluemix plumie slash
a Ws. So that's the automation framework, and AWS.
And then we need this process, because we're going
to see if there's any arguments when the program
is called. Now, we're going to make this program.
So we can call it from the command line. And it's
normally going to create a website, but we want to
make it so if we want, we can also destroy the
website from AWS. So that's why we're allowing
the the user to put in an argument destroy after
the program name when they're running the program.
So that's what this does it figured out figures
out if this is going to be destroying the website,
if not, it's going to be creating the
website. So let's go over here. And
so let me just show you kind of the whole thing at
a glance really quick, we have this run program,
and we have this whole run program. And at
the end, we run the program, we just call that
function, and then we catch if there's any errors.
So let's see what's in that function. Well,
the first thing in this function is our plumie.
Program. So this, this plumie program is in the
inline function format, which is just a slightly
different than than what we saw with the Python.
So unlike a traditional plumie program, inline
functions don't require a separate package on
disk. So we won't need a pluing dot Yamo
file. Inline programs are just functions.
And they can be in they can also be imported
from another package. But in this case,
we are creating it right in this file
here. So this so this first section,
we are defining the plumie program that we
want to run as a function within the overall
program. And it looks just like a standard
plumie program. So we create the site bucket,
which is very similar to what we saw in the
Python code. And this is just just like that,
we're creating the site bucket, and
we're specifying the index document.
And then this is the the HTML that we're going
to put into the site. Now remember, in Python, we
had the user supply this information. But in this
case, we're just putting it right in the program.
And then we are running the index file into the
site bucket. So that's the index content is the
content in the buckets, one, the one we already
defined up there. And so you should see a lot
of similarities with the Python code. And then
we're creating the s3 bucket policy to allow
people to read everything in there. So this
data, again, is just right from the AWS, all this
information is what we have to AWS needs to say
that anybody can access the files in the bucket,
which in our case, are the is the index html file.
And then we refer to the bucket right here. Okay,
so here's where we actually create the policy. And
we're going to apply what we create right up here.
And then we are going to return the basically
like a key value pair, the website URL
is going to be the website endpoint, which we're
gonna need to be able to access the website. And
the website URL is just going to be the website
endpoint, which will need to access the website.
And now we're going to be
associating it with a stack.
So as with existing plumie programs, we need
to associate this plumie program with a stack.
The automation API provides methods to
create or select stacks. And they're
in JavaScript is just like, very similar to
what it's like in Python. So this is going to
do the Create Your create or select stack.
So it's either going to create a new one,
or if already exist, it's going to select the
stack, it would already exist if we're trying
to destroy it. So the first time we run this
program is creating it. If we run the program
again with the destroy, then it's going to
select the stack that already exists. And
just like with the Python code, we
are going to install the AWS plugin.
We're going to set this configuration and
there could be a default configuration
that's already been set up, but if not, it's
going to use this one. The with AWS region
And then we're just going to refresh the stack.
And you can see what it does right on here,
it compares the current stacks resource state
with the state known to exist in the actual cloud
provider. And then any such changes are adapted
into the current stack. And both of these here are
configuring the AWS plugin, the plumie AWS plugin.
And we're just using the stack object to set the
region and the provider. Okay, and if we go down,
this is what we already talked about. If the
destroy argument has been passed, then we'll do
stack dot destroy, which will destroy everything
on volumi, and will also destroy everything on
AWS. So anything that's been created on AWS will
be destroyed. And then the program will exit here.
But if it doesn't get destroyed, we'll go down
to this. So await stack.up Where up is update.
And we are choosing to have a callback,
which is going to the standard output
and doing console that info. So it's outputting
everything to the standard output. But you can
do other things with this callback function. So
you could choose to take different actions, if
there were no resources updated, for example. Or
you could use the stack outputs to drive another
plumbing program within the same automation
program. So that's with having the callback
function, it opens up a lot of possibilities to
what you can do after this update takes place.
And then is going to log the
URL that we've set way up here.
So then we can go to the URL, and then it's
going well, then, then that's the end of that
function. And here we run the function. So
let's test this out. I'm going to save this.
And then I'm just going to do node index.js.
And here's the website URL. So I can just copy
this. And then I'll go to in the web browser.
Okay, here it is in the web browser, hello world.
And you can see even says hello s3 appear,
because we set the title of the page.
And you can see it's hosted on Amazon AWS.
Okay, now I'm gonna run this program again,
node index js. But this time, I'm going to
pass in an argument, destroy. Let me just confirm
that is what the destroy. So if I pass in destroy
as you can see, everything's been deleted,
we have four resources that were deleted.
The s3 WePlay, bucket, bucket
policy, the bucket object,
that node here. Okay, they've been deleted. And
then you can also run another command to remove
the stack completely. This in the Python file, we
actually did run that command in here, we didn't,
but we can always run that manually. And then
if we go and refresh on the page 404 not found.
So I hope that gave you a good sense of
how the JavaScript and the Python works,
and the similarities and the differences. And
there you have it. Our JavaScript program is
able to provision infrastructure just like our
Python program. So I hope you can take these
concepts and this knowledge and start applying it
to your own projects. Well, thanks for watching.